.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Erwartungsvolle Klänge *
Wenn ich hier stehe,
ist es eine Realität für mich,
dass mein Papa nicht mehr da ist.
Fatoumattas Vater wurde während
der Diktatur in Gambia ermordet.
Genau hier
wurde mein Papa verhaftet.
Der Vater
war ein bekannter Politiker,
sein Begräbnis ein Massenevent.
Mit seinem Tod begann für Fatoumatta
eine Lebensaufgabe.
Whoever arrested my father,
let him know that he has a family.
Für den Vater
und gegen das Vergessen kämpfen.
Das wusstest du nicht.
Ich erzähle es dir jetzt.- Okay.
Eine Aufgabe,
die sie bis nach Bellinzona
ans Bundesstrafgericht führt.
Hier ist Ousman Sonko angeklagt,
wegen schwerster Verbrechen
während der Diktatur.
Ich begleite Fatoumatta.
Kann ihr ein Schweizer Verfahren
Gerechtigkeit bringen?
Was treibt sie an?
Es ist Montag früh.
Morgenroutine bei Fatoumatta Sandeng
und Tochter Sumaya.
Doch der heutige Tag
ist alles andere als gewöhnlich:
Fatoumatta wird erstmals
das Bundesstrafgericht betreten.
Wie lange haben Sie
auf diesen Tag gewartet?
Ja, sechs oder sieben Jahre.
Seit 2016.
Also sehr lange. Ich hatte gehofft.
Okay, er hätte früher kommen können,
aber jetzt ist der Tag da.
Jetzt gehen wir. Finally.
Ich bin bereit,
aber es kommen doch ...
... viele Emotionen auf.
Ja ... Mal schauen.
So, gehen wir.
Du musst dich eincremen.
Fatoumattas Vater hatte in Gambia
für Demokratie gekämpft
und sich gegen das Regime gestellt.
2016 wurde er
brutal gefoltert und ermordet.
Wie präsent ist Ihr Vater heute?
Mein Vater ist heute voll präsent.
Man hat das Gefühl, er sei hier.
Wie die anderen Opfer,
die gefoltert wurden.
Die sind ja immer noch da.
Leider ist mein Papa nicht hier.
Ich bin heute für ihn anwesend.
Anwesend
am Prozess gegen Ousman Sonko.
Dieser war viele Jahre
Innenminister in Gambia und soll -
so die Anklage -
auch den Tod von Fatoumattas Vater
mitverschuldet haben.
Es wird anstrengend für ihn,
mich anzugucken.
Er muss mir viele Antworten geben.
Ich habe so viele Fragen für ihn.
Warum? Wie?
Warum wurde mein Papa getötet?
Ich glaube, er wird
die Fragen in meinen Augen sehen,
ohne dass ich etwas sagen.
Und es ist mir wichtig,
dass er das sieht.
Fatoumatta teilt sich das Airbnb
mit Fatou Camara.
Auch sie ein Folteropfer.
Beide Frauen sind
als Privatklägerinnen am Prozess.
Wenige Wochen zuvor in Gambia
an der westafrikanischen Küste.
* Zufriedene Musik *
Ich bin hier
geboren und aufgewachsen.
Gambia ist alles.
Das ist mein Motherland, right?
Ich mache alles hier.
Mein Vater wurde hier geboren.
Er hat für das Land gekämpft.
Er wurde hier gefoltert und getötet.
Gambia war alles für ihn.
Und es ist auch alles
für mich und meine Familie.
Aber nicht nur ich, auch Fatoumatta
ist nur zu Besuch hier.
Sie lebt in Deutschland,
mit ihren zwei kleinen Kindern
und ihrem gambischen Ehemann.
Dieser kam fürs Studium nach Europa.
Es ist schwierig,
so weit weg von Gambia zu sein.
Oft passiert hier etwas Wichtiges
und ich kann dann
in dem Moment nicht vor Ort sein.
Also, ich muss zuerst hinfliegen.
Das mache ich manchmal,
wenn ich Geld und Zeit habe.
Aber es ist nicht einfach.
Die Diktatur in Gambia
erlebte Fatoumatta hautnah.
Als sie zwei Jahre alt war, 1996,
übernahm Diktator Yahya Jammeh
die Macht
und herrschte über 20 Jahre lang.
Menschen verschwanden,
wurden gefoltert und getötet.
Zurück blieb ein Land
mit vielen Wunden.
Fatoumatta hat das Erinnern daran
zu ihrem Lebensinhalt gemacht.
Sie gründete eine Stiftung
im Gedenken an den Vater.
Wir haben im ganzen Land,
in ganz Gambia ...
Wir haben fünf Museen ausgesucht
und dann Ausstellungen gemacht.
Wir haben diese Ausstellung gemacht.
Ich war noch nie hier.
Das wird mein erster Besuch.
Hoffentlich finden wir es schön.
* Erwartungsvolle Klänge *
Hi.
Fatoumatta will mit ihrer Stiftung
die Geschichte zugänglich machen.
Eine der Ausstellungen liegt in
einer historischen Festung in Barra.
Madi Ceesay ist ganz, ganz wichtig.
Jetzt the Honorable Madi Ceesay.
Er ist auch ein Opfer.
Er wurde damals verhaftet.
Er war Journalist.
Er wurde verhaftet und gefoltert
und sitzt jetzt im Parlament.
Wir werden Madi Ceesay
später noch kennenlernen.
Natürlich ist auch Vater Solo Sandeng
Teil der Ausstellung.
So.
Hm.
Was bedeutet Ihnen das?
Ich würde sagen,
dass das meine Liebe ist.
Es ist immer wahnsinnig ...
Jetzt werde ich emotional. Oh.
Oh.
* Schniefen *
Also ...
- Das schmerzt, oder?
Ja.
Es ist so wichtig,
dass wir alle Storys aufzeigen.
Aber wenn ich hier stehe,
ist es eine Realität für mich,
dass mein Papa nicht mehr da ist.
Obwohl ich jeden Tag damit lebe.
Ich weiss es ja, aber es wird mir
immer wieder neu bewusst.
Ich habe etwas gesehen.
Warte. Weg damit.
So.
Fatoumatta trauert.
Aber da ist
auch eine ganz grundsätzliche Angst:
dass die Verbrechen der Diktatur
vergessen gehen.
Wir fanden, dass die Leute,
die nicht in Gambia sind,
auch davon wissen sollten.
Wie Nelson Mandela.
Der ist überall bekannt.
Das sind unser Nelson Mandelas.
* Ungemütliche Klänge *
Ich habe Angst.
Das ist die gambische Kultur:
Wir vergessen viel.
Wir vergessen und vergeben
und gehen weiter.
Das Leben geht weiter.
Diese Leute
gehören zu unserer Geschichte.
Wenn wir sie vergessen,
haben wir einen Teil
der gambischen Geschichte vergessen.
Das Ende der Diktatur in Gambia
ist erst sieben Jahre her.
Manche Opfer leben noch
und sind wichtige Zeitzeugen -
auch vor dem Schweizer Gericht.
Fatoumatta
trifft Mitklägerin Fatou Camara.
Die mehrfache Grossmutter
hat mit Fatoumattas Vater für
ein demokratisches Gambia gekämpft.
Damals hatten wir
einen schrecklichen Präsidenten.
Wenn er dich verhaftet hat,
wurdest du gefoltert und getötet.
Durch Wahlen
konnte er nicht abgesetzt werden.
Am Tag,
als Fatoumattas Vater ermordet wurde,
wurde auch sie
verhaftet und gefoltert.
Sehen Sie meine Hand?
Ich kann bis heute
nichts Schweres damit halten.
Ehrlich gesagt:
Alle Opfer haben gelitten.
Wir haben alle gelitten.
Fatou Camara ist besorgt,
dass es heute in Gambia wieder in
eine falsche Richtung gehen könnte.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich an diesen Tag
denke, bricht es mir das Herz.
Ich habe viel geweint.
- Sie hat grosse Angst,
dass die autokratischen Zeiten
zurückkommen könnten.
Noch sind sie nicht da.
Aber nicht nur sie, viele Menschen
in Gambia haben Angst,
dass die alten Zeiten zurückkehren.
Ein Gefühl von Ohnmacht.
Umso wichtiger sei die juristische
Aufarbeitung, sagt Fatou Camara.
Auch der Prozess in der Schweiz.
Das Verfahren
ist wichtig für Gambia.
Damit die Wahrheit ans Licht kommt.
So wäre jeder achtsam,
der an die Macht kommt.
Sie wüssten, dass sie bestraft
werden, wenn sie das Gesetz brechen.
* Angespannte Klänge *
Heute ist ein besonders
schwieriger Tag für Fatoumatta.
Sie nimmt uns mit
an jene verhängnisvollen Orte,
wo ihr Vater
verhaftet und getötet wurde.
Das ist die Kreuzung,
an der mein Papa verhaftet wurde.
Genau hier.
* Angespannte Klänge *
Ihr seht: Das ist eine busy road.
Das ist ganz ...
Das ist das Zentrum,
wo fast alles passiert.
Es geschah um 14 Uhr.
So gegen 14 Uhr, sage ich.
Mein Papa machte an dem Tag
eine Demonstration.
Solo Sandeng und seine Mitstreiter
demonstrierten für faire Wahlen.
Eine peaceful demonstration.
Das war friedlich.
Dann kam die Polizei.
Und genau hier
wurde mein Papa verhaftet.
Das war am 14. April 2016.
Ein Tag,
den ich nie vergessen werde.
Dieser Tag
hat unser ganzes Leben verändert.
Als Sie Kind waren,
war dieses Risiko immer präsent,
dass er evtl. verhaftet wird?
Ja. Mein Papa
wurde nicht nur einmal verhaftet,
sondern mehrmals.
Ich habe vergessen, wie viele Male.
Aber mehrmals.
Bei der Verhaftung
vor der letzten Verhaftung
war er 22 Tage in Mile 2.
Das ist das zentrale Gefängnis.
Da war er fast einen Monat lang.
Wie war das für Sie?
Als kleine Kinder
hatten wir Angst um ihn.
Für meine Mama war das anstrengend.
Ich erinnere mich daran,
dass wir ihm gesagt haben ...
Das war, nachdem er
einen Monat im Gefängnis war.
Wir sagten: "Es wäre besser,
du gingest nach Senegal."
"Lass all das hinter dir."
"Vielleicht kommen wir mit dir mit
oder wir bleiben hier."
"Geh einfach. Sie haben gesagt,
sie werden dich umbringen."
Mein Papa sagte: "Wenn ihr wollt,
bringe ich euch nach Senegal."
"Aber ich bin hier geboren.
Ich werde für Gambia kämpfen."
"Ich höre nicht auf.
Ich werde hier sterben."
Und das war's.
Wir konnten gar nicht mehr sagen.
Das war so: "Dieser Mann wird Gambia
nie verlassen. Geht nicht."
Das war sein Stil.
Die Angst scheint verflogen.
Geblieben sind Stolz und Bewunderung
für den Vater.
Wir fahren weiter,
auf den Spuren von Fatoumattas Vater.
Unterwegs passieren wir
das berüchtigte Gefängnis Mile 2 -
von Diktator Jammeh sarkastisch
auch "Fünf-Sterne-Hotel" genannt.
Man nennt es "Five Star Hotel",
because when you are taken there,
that's it. You get treated.
Wenn man hier hingebracht wurde,
bekam man eine "Behandlung".
Heisst: Folter.
Come, come, come.
Wir sind in der Hauptstadt Banjul.
Hierhin kam ihr Vater damals, 2016.
Zum Geheimdienst.
Während der Diktatur "NIA" genannt
und eine gefürchtete Behörde.
Das ist der NIA, wo mein Papa
gefoltert und getötet wurde.
Das ist natürlich
ein sehr emotionaler Ort für mich.
Für uns alle als Familie.
Und eigentlich für Gambia.
Hier ist fast alles passiert.
Viele wurden hier gefoltert.
Madi und all die anderen.
An diesem Ort,
wo fast alle injustice passiert ist.
Können Sie sich an den Tag erinnern,
als Sie erfahren haben,
dass Ihr Vater verhaftet worden ist?
- Ja. Es war ein Donnerstag.
Ich war im Büro, ich war arbeiten.
Frühmorgens an diesem Tag
sagte er mir, er gehe raus.
"Wir machen heute
eine Demonstration."
"Kann sein, dass ich zurückkomme,
oder auch nicht."
"Pass auf.
Pass auf die Familie auf."
Das ist mir geblieben.
"Pass auf die Familie auf",
bedeutet doch viel, hm?
Und er kam nicht zurück.
Er gab mir
diese grosse Verantwortung:
"Pass auf die Familie auf."
Das ist enorm.
Und er kam nicht zurück.
Tagelang ist unklar,
ob Solo Sandeng noch lebt.
Wir haben gesagt: "We need
Solo Sandeng dead or alive."
"Wir brauchen Solo Sandeng,
ob er tot oder lebendig ist."
Fatoumatta exponiert sich stark.
Sie stellt sich öffentlich
hinter ihren Vater.
Whoever arrested my father,
let him know that he has a family.
And that he is important to us.
I am standing alone.
I am not expecting
anybody to stand behind me.
Bis es für sie
und ihre Familie zu heikel wird.
Es hiess: "Wir müssen Fatoumatta
verhaften. Sie redet zu viel."
"Sie macht zu viel."
An dem Tag, am 16. April,
gab es eine Demonstration.
Und ich sprach mit den Medien.
Wir mussten uns
bis eine Woche danach verstecken.
Dann gingen wir nach Senegal
und blieben neun Monate dort.
Bis Jammeh dann weg war.
(TV)
... fired tear gas on protestors.
Der Tod von Fatoumattas Vater
ist ein Wendepunkt.
V.a. junge Leute
gehen auf die Strasse,
lassen sich nicht mehr einschüchtern.
Wenig später ist die Zeit
von Diktator Yahya Jammeh abgelaufen.
Er setzt sich ins Ausland ab.
(TV) Jammeh did a very unsual thing
by accepting defeat so publicly.
Sein Tod hat was ausgelöst.
- Der hat was ausgelöst.
Deswegen haben wir heute
eine neue Regierung.
Sonst hätten wir gar nichts gehabt.
Sorry.
- Hello, sir.
Dann wird das Interview unterbrochen.
Dass wir hier stehen?
Darf man nicht hier stehen?
Der Geheimdienstmitarbeiter verlangt,
dass wir uns entfernen.
Bei Fatoumatta
weckt der gambische Geheimdienst
auch heute noch viel Wut.
Was bedeutet das für Sie?
- Das?
Niemand kann mir sagen,
ich solle weggehen.
Ich kenne meine Rechte.
Ich gehe nicht weg.
Ich habe gefragt,
ob es verboten sei, hier zu stehen.
Nein? Dann gehe ich nicht weg.
Sie sind es gewohnt,
andere zu bedrohen.
Das mache ich nicht mit. So bin ich.
So war mein Papa
und so bin auch ich.
Das geht nicht.
Wir müssen dieses System ändern.
So kämpfen wir.
Darum sagt er,
ich sei "interesting".
Das stimmt. I'm interesting.
Die Dreharbeiten, das Erinnern,
wühlen viel auf in Fatoumatta.
Gambia
ist heute ein demokratisches Land.
Es ist möglich,
die eigene Meinung zu äussern,
seine Rechte einzufordern.
Aber gleichzeitig sind viele
Polizisten und Sicherheitsleute,
die während der Diktatur
im Dienst waren, immer noch da.
Da ist dieses Gefühl,
diese Gedanken ...
Besonders die Leute,
die im Geheimdienst, in der Polizei
oder im Militär sind ...
Weil sie in Uniform sind,
können sie machen, was sie wollen.
Das ist noch ein langer Weg.
Es gibt noch viel zu tun.
* Erwartungsvolle Klänge *
* Man hört verschiedene Stimmen. *
Wir sind mit Fatoumatta
bei ihrer Mutter zu Hause.
* Sie sprechen gambisch. *
Wir bereiten heute
eine Erdnussbuttersauce zu.
Das ist ein richtig leckeres
gambisches Gericht.
Das kennen alle in Gambia.
Das mögen viele.
Und das kochen wir heute.
Die 29-Jährige ist
in einer Grossfamilie aufgewachsen.
Sie ist das drittälteste
von neun Kindern.
Vermissen Sie das,
wenn Sie in Deutschland sind?
Sehr.
Ich habe es nicht ...
Ich koche immer alleine.
Sumaya ist meistens auch nicht da.
Sie ist im Kindergarten.
Ich muss alles vorbereiten
und alleine kochen.
Was hält Ihre Mutter davon, dass Sie
weit weg in Deutschland leben?
Es ist keine kurze Strecke,
sodass ich
einfach ein Taxi nehmen könnte.
Manchmal macht mir das zu schaffen.
V.a. wenn ich die Nachricht bekomme,
dass du krank bist oder so etwas.
Wir sehen uns manchmal
nur einmal pro Jahr
für, sagen wir, vier Wochen.
Vielleicht sechs.
Das ist schwierig für jede Mutter.
Und für mich auch.
Der verstorbene Vater
ist im Haus der Familie omnipräsent.
Solo Sandeng wurde nach seinem Tod
für seine Politaktivitäten
ausgezeichnet.
We had another,
the Peacemaker Award.
That he won.
* Sie sprechen gambisch. *
Und das ist Opa.
Das bin ich. Ohne Kopftuch damals.
Früher.
* Sie sprechen gambisch. *
Kuck mal. Da ist Opa.
Ja.
- Du hast Opa nie kennengelernt.
Aber hier in Gambia
ist er sehr bekannt.
Wusstest du das?
Opa hat für Gambia gekämpft.
Er hat das sehr gut gemacht.
Deswegen kennen ihn alle.
Alle hier kennen Opa.
Das wusstest du nicht, oder?
Jetzt erzähle ich es dir.- Okay.
Ja. Deswegen. Opa Solo.
Opa Solo.
- Mhm. Das ist Opa Solo.
* Sie sprechen gambisch. *
Was that you?
- No.
Mein Ehemann
kämpfte für die Freiheit
und das führte zu seinem Tod.
Auch für uns
war es in Gambia nicht mehr sicher.
Sie bedrohten uns, bis wir das Land
verliessen und nach Senegal gingen.
Es war extrem schockierend.
Es heisst immer:
"Wir werden keinen zweiten Solo
in dieser Familie haben."
Er bedeutet ...
Er ist viel mehr
als nur ein Vater oder ...
Wir vermissen ihn.
Alle in der Familie vermissen ihn.
Das letzte Mal
hat mein Onkel gesagt,
dass es bis jetzt niemanden gibt,
der Solos Platz einnehmen kann.
Der wird immer leer bleiben.
Keiner kann seine Rolle
komplett einnehmen.
Ich finde es sehr gut, dass du
das Erbe deines Vaters fortführst.
Jedes Kind sollte das Vermächtnis
seiner Eltern fortsetzen.
Fatoumattas Leben ist prallvoll.
Sie hat zwei kleine Kinder,
studiert Islamwissenschaften
und führt ihre Stiftung
in Erinnerung an den Vater.
Ist dies alles
manchmal auch eine Bürde?
Manchmal ist es zu viel.
Mit der Familie, mit den Kindern ...
Man hat viel zu tun,
aber es ist nie eine Bürde.
Wirklich nicht.
Das kommt von Herzen.
Man möchte das machen.
Man muss alles dafür tun.
Deswegen ... Egal,
wenn es manchmal auch zu viel ist.
Man denkt einfach:
"Ich muss das machen."
Müssen und wollen
liegen manchmal nah beieinander.
Eine Ambivalenz,
die wohl auch Kraft kostet.
Allah.
Mein Kampfgeist und alles,
meine Inspiration ...
Das alles kommt aus der Religion.
Meine Religion
gibt mir die Power dafür.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich das formulieren soll,
aber meine Religion
ist alles für mich.
Darum
folge ich meiner Religion komplett.
* Gespräche auf Gambisch *
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Gambia bemüht sich, die
autokratischen Zeiten aufzuarbeiten.
Eine Wahrheitskommission hat sich
mit den Verbrechen im Land befasst.
Doch Gerichtsverfahren
wie jenes in der Schweiz
fanden hier nur ganz wenige statt.
Teils auch weil bis vor Kurzem
die dafür nötigen Gesetze fehlten.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Bevor das Verfahren in Bellinzona
beginnt,
steht für Fatoumatta
noch ein gewichtiger Besuch an:
im Parlament von Gambia.
Die Hauptarbeit hier: die Gesetze aus
der Zeit der Diktatur reformieren.
Im Parlament sitzt auch er:
Madi Ceesay.
Ceesay hat früher
als Journalist gearbeitet
und die Diktatur von Yahya Jammeh
am eigenen Leib erfahren.
Er wurde gefoltert
und hat einen Sohn verloren.
Was uns Opfern fehlt,
ist Gerechtigkeit.
Es ist entmutigend zu sehen,
dass Menschen,
die unschuldige Gambier getötet
haben, immer noch unter uns leben.
Es ist gut, dass wir
ein Gerichtsverfahren in der Schweiz
und eines in Deutschland haben.
Aber das
betrifft nur ein, zwei Leute.
Der grösste Teil der Täter
ist bei uns.- In Gambia.
Dann ruft die Pflicht: Madi Ceesay
muss zurück in den Parlamentssaal.
Als Politiker
ist er selber in der Verantwortung,
die Gesetze zu reformieren.
Herr Ceesay,
ich habe noch eine Frage an Sie:
Sie kannten
den verstorbenen Solo Sandeng.
Wenn Sie Fatoumatta heute sehen,
erkennen Sie in ihr den Vater wieder?
Seinen Aktivismus, sein Engagement?
Ja, genau.
Tatsächlich
ist das für mich sehr emotional.
Fatoumatta
ist wie eine Tochter für mich.
Wenn ich sie sehe,
sehe ich das Abbild meines Freundes,
meines Bruders,
des verstorbenen Solo Sandeng.
I'm sorry.
Es tut mir leid.
Möge seine Seele
in vollkommenem Frieden ruhen.
Thank you.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Hätten Sie auch einen Platz da drin?
- Ach, ich weiss nicht.
Ich glaube, ich bin noch nicht
bereit. Oder vielleicht doch?
Momentan noch nicht.
- Sitzen Sie irgendwann im Parlament?
Ja. Ich denke,
dass ich Wichtiges zu sagen habe.
Und das hier ist ein Ort,
wo ich genau das machen kann.
Vielleicht auch Präsidentin?
- Präsidentin?
Ich?
Das glaube ich nicht,
aber ich weiss es nicht.
Aber es wird gut.
Es gibt vieles,
das ich verbessern möchte.
Und ich glaube, das kann man nur,
wenn man an der Macht ist.
Nur wenn man fühlt,
was andere in Gambia fühlen.
Das war kein Nein.
- Ja, das war kein Nein.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Der Prozess gegen Ousman Sonko
beginnt.
Das Schweizer Bundesstrafgericht
verhandelt Gambias Diktatur.
Hallo again.
- Hello.
Fatoumatta trifft ihre Anwältin.
Heute wird sie erstmals
an der Verhandlung mit dabei sein.
* Erwartungsvolle Klänge *
Die gambischen Medien
berichten während des Prozesses
im Stundentakt.
Wie viel hat der
damalige Innenminister Sonko gewusst?
Wie viel hat er geduldet, angeordnet?
Ist er schuld
am Tod von Fatoumattas Vater?
Sonko selber bestreitet die Vorwürfe.
Es gilt die Unschuldsvermutung.
Im Gericht
hat Fatoumatta den Angeklagten
nun von Angesicht
zu Angesicht gesehen.
Bye-bye.
Was fühlen Sie?
Äh ...
Interessant.
Ich war da
und habe von ihm selber gehört.
Ich habe gesehen,
wie das alles läuft usw.
So wird es lebendig, jetzt da
zu sein und alles selber zu hören.
Was wäre,
wenn er freigesprochen wird?
Dann wissen wir immer noch,
dass wir gewonnen haben.
Das sage ich immer.
Zumindest haben wir etwas gemacht.
Wir hatten wenigstens den Mut,
ihn hierherzubringen
und die Wahrheit zu sagen.
Zu zeigen, was in uns ist.
Auch wenn sie sagen,
dass sie keinen Link finden können
und er freigesprochen wird.
Das bedeutet immer noch das Gleiche,
nämlich ganz viel für uns.
Das Urteil
werden die Schweizer Richter
in den nächsten Monaten fällen.
Und Fatoumatta?
Wann ist ihre Aufgabe erfüllt?
Wenn ich nicht mehr lebe,
vielleicht.
Das
ist ein lebenslanger Kampf für mich.
Mein Papa war da,
bis er nicht mehr da war.
Es wird immer Menschen geben,
die andere nicht respektieren.
Die die Menschenrechte
nicht respektieren.
Und das möchte ich stoppen.
Das muss ...
Einfach so, bis zum Ende.
* Lebendige Musik *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2024